I think as humans we all have a
preoccupation of looking dumb we're
social creatures hierarchical creatures
and that we don't shame ourselves
humiliate ourselves but recognizing that
by Zig England everyone else's zagging
with that particular context you can
actually develop a superpower and that
is asking dumb questions and this came
up repeatedly when I was interviewing
incredible performers world-class
performers meaning investors
entrepreneurs writers you name it for
tools of titans in the new book and
asking dumb questions can take many
forms so I give you a few examples
Malcolm Gladwell is very good asking
so-called dumb questions you learn that
from his father who is a mathematician
had no intellectual insecurities
whatsoever just did not care about
looking stupid and he would constantly
ask where he would first say I don't
understand please explain that I don't
understand can you explain that I don't
understand can you explain that he was
literally he might ask that pen son or
couple and Malcolm mentioned that he
imagines sometimes what the conversation
would look like between his dad and
Bernie Madoff because is that never
would have invested he just would have
at he sort of said I don't understand
that at all explain that to me over and
over again until Madoff laughter who had
got so frustrated to leave but if we
look at another sphere say investing
Chris Sacca
a close friend of mine billionaire
incredible tech investor just immaculate
track record is very good at asking dumb
questions and this applies to in the
very early days where he did something
very clever which was at Google when he
was just entry-level guy really compared
certainly to say the Wonder Twins the
founders and others he would go to as
many high-level meetings as possible
most of what she was not invited to he
would show up at a meeting with a Sergey
or whenever and you walk in and sit down
and they'd look at each other and ask
him what he was doing there you go oh
I'll just take notes
okay yes we get students on all these
high-level meetings and eventually at
some point let's say you got through
five or ten of those and people started
to just expect him to be around he would
then ask these dumb questions so the
pink elephant in the room why is no one
asking this what seems like a very
obvious question and he's created some
incredible breakthroughs and investing
as a result of that the asking of dumb
questions can certainly apply to
exploring any topic or interviewing so
Alex Blumberg who's co-founder of gimlet
media which has a slew of gigantic
podcast hits just a factory for podcast
blockbusters he was the co-creator of
Planet Money which is a very successful
radio and podcast show and for instance
during the subprime economic crisis he
asked the question that no one else
seemed to be asking but it was just
sitting right in front of millions of
people who couldn't quite figure out
what the hell happened and it was why
would banks lend money to people who
stand next to no chance to paying it
back and so very often the dumb question
that is sitting right there that no one
seems to be asking is the smartest
question you can ask not only is it the
smartest most incisive but if you want
to ask it and you're reasonably smart I
guarantee you there are other people who
want to ask they're just embarrassed to
do so and in this case if you can
override that embarrassment and be the
one last dumb questions you can end up
having best-selling books you can end up
having a huge blockbuster of a podcast
or many you could end up picking the
next Ebor it is a superpower in a world
that is governed by shame and perhaps
political correctness more and more so
people are not saying what's on their
mind they're not asking what's on their
mind and the questions here are the most
powerful
you
[Music]